hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar cell
culture bioprocess scale up workflow
from bench to pilot production scale
using single use bioreactors
i'm alvin alvarez of rappendorf and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lap roots
and brought to you by eppendorf
eppendorf ag is a leading company
in the life sciences that develops and
sells instruments consumables
and services for liquid handling sample
handling and cell handling
to learn more visit please visit
www.appendorf.com
the webinar will be around 30 minutes
and we encourage you to participate
today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply click typing type them
into
the ask question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we'll
have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing
educational credits please follow the
process to obtain your credits by
clicking on the continuing educational
credits window i'd like to welcome now
our three speakers who are going to
address different aspects
first marsha the head of bioprocess
applications at eppendorf
rich miro a business manager by a
process at eppendorf
and as the last person amanda suttle a
research scientist at appendorf
with that i hand over to ma you may now
begin your presentation
thanks alvin
presentation today will have three
sections as elvin had
pointed out so i will be starting it
with the scale-up strategies
and the followed by the bioflow 720
introduction
and then amanda will talk about the
workflow
of involving the 720 using the scale-up
strategies
um as elba mentioned i am masha i manage
the evander
file process applications labs
we have a lab in enfield connecticut usa
and another applications lab in unit
germany
and this work on the 720 scale up
lab work is conducted in field
so let's start with a white scale up
the purpose of the cell culture scale up
for most people
is to bridge the gap between the r d
and production typically
scientists use bench scale for example
for
or small scale for optimization work and
until they get really really good yield
and to bring that yield into production
scale
it is not a trivial task so this
uh scale up effort often involves the
intermediate step
for the pilot scale that goes from 50 to
2000 liters
and the introduction of the 720
controller
is for managing the the pilot scale
i'll start with introducing some of the
scale-up strategies we investigated in
the applications lab
one of them is the constant mixing time
it is a popular strategy from the
chemical engineering field
and which precedes to the bioprocess
business
and when we look into the constant
missing time
we realized that it wasn't actually
practical enough because the small scale
tends to have extremely fast
mixing time and in many cases actually
does not overlap
with a bench scale or a pilot scale
so we weren't able to find constant
mixing time
to implement this particular strategy
the next one which we do use and it's
really
fairly straightforward is constant tip
speed
the constant tip speed maintains a
constant shearing force for the cells
so for cell culture at least
you're not subjecting the cells at a
different shear force or a little hotter
harsher conditions on a larger scale
the method does work when the scale are
not too far apart
especially popular for smaller companies
where
exact yield matching isn't critical
and in the to the right we have one
application node where we use the
constant tip speed
uh to scale from 0.25 liter to 1 liter
those are small scale
so there's a barcode the points into the
actual application node
the next scale up strategy is really
popular
the constant kla what we consider
as a former gold standard
a constant kla for anaerobic uh a cell
culture
aerobic bioreactor culture process
will give you a constant yield
the difficult part is the kla tends to
change with most of the parameters used
in culture
whether it's agitation speed or amount
of gassing
so that means to match a kla between one
scale to another
we would have to analyze many many kelly
parameters
and that is a kind of tedious
we do publish kle numbers on selected
vessels
however our scale up strategies that
we've been practicing
is the next one constant power overwatch
constant pv this is what we consider
the current gold standard for the
biological scale
the big advantage is a simplicity
one would only need to measure one power
number
per vessel and it doesn't really change
based on the vessel conditions and with
the power number which is
typically measured by torque impeller
torque
you can see the picture to the right we
have this apparatus
over on top of the vessel the little red
piece in the middle is the
torque sensor then there are
two adapters flexible adapters when
above and one below
adapt the torque sensor to the shaft
which measures
impeller torque through this setup
and the power number um
[Music]
is measured one per vessel
and the the disadvantage is is this
particular method
uh it's not something that everybody
already have in place
if you measure kla you don't need any of
these
anybody can do it but to measure the
power numbers you kind of need to set up
this
sort of customized apparatus
so here is an example we have released
the power number for all the bioblue
vessels and the barcode links to the
presentation where this
particular part number sets are released
it was actually released into a
application
where we did a scale up of chill culture
in the bioproof
so in the next slide you can see
with the power number then one would
calculate
the power over volume and when we plot
the
pv over different tip speed on different
vessels
this will allow you to
find your parameters for constant pv
scala
on the right hand side you can see that
we put into a
a sort of two line indicating the scalab
zone
in this particular range of agitation
and the vessel chosen
you can look for overlapping power
numbers to conduct a constant pb
overlap lapping pv to conduct constant
pv scale up
and this stone changes when you change
or increase your
agitation speed so on the left hand side
the figure actually shows we go up to
about one
meter per second of keep speed the
increase the tip speed allows
a scale up to be done at a higher pv
levels
so the next one is an example when we
apply the constant pivot scale up
strategy
to the three selected vessels strong
point three
c three 3c and 50c
and we were able to get a really nice
cell culture yield matching so the
picture on the left shows the cell
growth
profile between the three different
vessels with no optimization other than
maintain the pv being constant
and to the right is the antibody
production here
this is a chill cell line producing a
human monoclonal antibody
so on the right hand side you can see
the antibody production yield was
maintained very nicely
so these strategies are gonna are used
in later on you will see the
presentation
these strategies are used in our scale
up
using the new uh bioflow 720
so that concludes my section i will pass
the presentation to reach mirror
okay thank you ma and hello to everyone
thank you for joining us today my name
is rich miro
i'm the business manager at eppendorf
responsible for bench
and pilot production systems today i'll
be providing a brief introduction
to the bioflow 720.
so as we all know bioprocess facilities
chase face many challenges today there's
resource limitations
limited space and often the challenge
of working with or using products for
multiple suppliers
and to help alleviate these challenges
and others
i'm proud to introduce the bioflow 720
designed based on four basic principles
scalability efficiency flexibility
and application driven the new product
features hardware and software designed
to facilitate workflow
and alleviate the challenges mentioned
which are commonly found in bioprocess
suites
i look at the first principle
scalability
as you can see from the illustration the
bioflow 720 adds additional scalability
to our already strong portfolio of
instruments
ranging from small parallel systems
through bench
and now pilot production this supports a
workflow from r
d to production for our customers
the system is compatible with the
thermoscientific high performa five to
one
single use bioreactor system with
volumes of 50 liter
to 2000 liter and when you combine that
with the existing eppendorf bioblue
single use portfolio
working volume ranges go from 100
milliliters
up to 2000 liters total
i think very impressive working volume
covers most applications
further supporting the element of
scalability
the advanced software features
integrated tools
which simplify tasks
as ma had mentioned we have a new tool
called
the scale up assist which allows for
quick
and easy scale up models be to be
developed
based on a variety of strategies
constant power
constant tip speed and a constant gas
flow
during the third part of the webinar
amanda will go over the tool
in more detail and she'll provide some
examples of how this has been used in
our laboratory
if i switch to the second principle
efficiency
the new software and instrument features
additional
software auto calibrate
and auto inflate both of which are
designed to save considerable time by
automating repetitive tasks
the auto calibrate polarizes
zeros and then spans do sensors
based on a repeatable computer logic
the screenshot you can see on the right
is an example of the
auto calibrate and the workflow for this
users would select whether they want to
calibrate a single or all do sensors
they would select whether or not the
calibration will be done inside or
outside of a vessel
select the zero point strategy
electronic
or nitrogen and then select
key variables like gas flow rate
agitation
and temperature as well as polarization
time simply press play and the system
automates the process
which can save up to eight hours if
you're looking at
an analog do sensor which requires six
to eight hours of polarization
so not only does it save time but it
also creates a
repeatable do calibration you know
operators
may select span or zero
at individual preference of time this
this process automates it and does it
the same way every time
the second feature the autoinflate
automatically adds gas to the bioprocess
container in two stages
after the first stage the bag is
inflated approximately 50 percent
there's a pause the bag can be adjusted
to make sure
that the impellers that the sensors and
other critical components are seated
properly
then the process is continued which
fills to 100 percent
uh preparing for media to be added
there are safety interlocks built in
this way if an exhaust
filter or any other blockage occurs the
process stops
if pressure is at or exceeds a specific
set point additionally
with efficiency the software is built
and designed
using the same user interface concepts
as our existing bio flow
320 and 120 products this
really simplifies the transition for
existing
customers as well as customers who may
be looking at products for
bench small scale or r d uh um
pilot production in the screenshot
examples on the left
you see an existing screen for the
bioflow 320
and then you see the same screen on the
right hand side for the bioflow 720
in principle they're almost they're
almost identical there's some new
features added to the bioflow 720
but the biggest adaptation was moving
from a
4x3 format to a 16x9
looking at the third principle
flexibility
the general eppendorf design design
philosophy
provides standard systems with
configurable options
and this allows us to design
a standard control system and meet the
benefits of
standard design practices while enabling
the ability to to configure it in
thousands
actually of different permutations
a couple examples the highly
configurable gas flow options
so up to five configurable tmfcs
thermal mass flow controllers can be
selected for
the overlay the sparge
an optional second sparge or a co2
stripping
and those tmfcs can be configured and
mixed and matched at different flows
to meet the preference or the demands of
the specific
application or process also
because of the digital nature of those
tmfcs they can be easily exchanged in
the future
if the instrument is needed for
different campaigns or different
purposes
from the perspective of sensors up to
four
sensor connections can be equipped on
the instrument
and they're compatible with both analog
ism mettler toledo or
digital as well as the hamilton sensors
there are several pump options watson
marla 314
pumps come standard but additional by
watson marlow 520 pumps can be added as
well as
additional 620 pumps could be plugged in
for
high flow requirements
looking at the fourth and final
principle
application driven the product is truly
designed for bio process one of the
elements we show here is the mobile
control station
allows the instrument to be quickly
moved from laboratory or suite to suite
if required that that allows for quick
deployment into a variety of
campaigns and a lot of flexibility the
overall footprint
of the controller is quite narrow 32
inches or 81 centimeters
it takes a very little lab space
the user access panel shown on the
instrument on the left hand side
closed in the image streamlines
and it protects sensitive sensitive
electronics
in the previous screen you could see it
open where an operator was connecting
sensors that panel allows cables to be
routed
through an integrated cable management
system
and out the bottom allows for both
organization
and protection and ease of cleaning
overall for the system so those are the
four key principles of the new product
please let me know if you have any
questions later
amanda
all right thank you wretch um my name is
amanda suttle i work in the
applications lab in enfield and today
we'll be presenting our scale up work
integrating our newest bio uh
family member the bioflow 720.
so here we have a typical bioprocess
antibody
production workflow overview
our workflow begins when we saw
ourselves
uh and this can typically take less than
a day between our preparations and
getting ourselves into
their incubator um when we move on to
the routine passaging and flask culture
scale up
that can depend on the inoculation
density you're trying to reach for how
long you're
in that phase of the workflow which
can be between two to three weeks of
culturing typically
for our study our routine passaging um
and seed train scale up was about two
weeks
and lastly we have our bioreactor so
again the stage can vary
depending on the user process um for
example a typical batch run
runs for about a week a fed batch can
take anywhere from two to three weeks
and a perfusion can last three or more
weeks
for this study we chose to run batch
runs
when designing our scale process it is
critical to
achieve matching growth curves and
production yields from shaker
to pilot scale production so what's our
secret for having
a robust inoculum that would be the new
new brunswick s41i which is pictured
here on the right
it combines precise temperature and co2
control with one of the best laboratory
shakers available
resulting in high cell yields and
viability the s41i has a wide range of
interchangeable dedicated platforms for
various sized flasks
and it is easy to change between
experiments allowing it to flexibly
adapt to your process
it also has one of the most important
features my favorite
feature the high temp disinfection
with a few simple clicks your shaking
incubator is sparkling clean and ready
to go for your next bio process
adventure
so why are constant parameters important
to any experiment
especially scale up keeping constant
parameters gives consistent results
which means really reliable data
constant parameters also reduce shock
factors to the cells that could
potentially have a negative effect on
your culture
like exhibiting a lag later on in your
bioreactor run
in addition when keeping scale up
processes in mind it is extremely
important to keep
constant parameters and reduce those
shock factors to achieve the matching
growth curves from small scale all the
way up to our pilot scale
so what is our main goal for achieving
perfect inoculation
we want to keep a viability 95 or higher
in our pre-bioreactor culture
so that our cells remain happy and
healthy when we put them into our
bioreactor
so how do we do this we track
initial flask culture in an excel file
and this file
includes past data so that we can
compare current data to get an idea
where our cells are tracking in growth
and viability
this is extremely important so that we
can quickly detect any outliers or
unforeseen variables
for instance we take a cell count every
day and look at our data
individually and how they compare to our
other flats that we're culturing
but the problem with doing only this is
that we're not able to see any changes
over time
and everything might look okay from one
day to the next but compared against
other data it might not actually be
and we don't want to inoculate our
bioreactor with subpar cultures
something else that has helped our uh
yeah our troll culture
was uh finding an optimal passage
schedule for ourselves
it seems simple but it's very important
if your
cells are passage too much it can lead
to unhappy cells
if they are passage too little ammonia
can build up and cause adverse
effects to your cells and in the initial
phases of development work this is
really important to uncover
we found that archo cells like to be
passage every other day for optimal
growth
next we monitor our ph and keep tight
parameters on them
this is especially true when it comes
time to inoculation of our bioreactor
we want to make sure that the bioreactor
culture medium and our cells
flask that are are at the same ph excuse
me
um we take offline samples to compare
and set our bioreactor ph loops that
point
accordingly so that they are not shocked
in their new environment
and lastly we try to keep ourselves
inside their optimal growing environment
aka the incubator
as much as possible we prepare
everything we need to pass with
ourselves ahead of time inside our bio
safety cabinet
temperature and ph can change
drastically outside the incubator
so we try to um we try to
like i said cut down on that and also
this also allows excuse me um for
settling to occur
and our cho cells are already prone to
comping so we don't want to
you know have them out too long
by following these steps we've acquired
the perfect inoculation
for our bioreactors with happy healthy
cells
so now that we have the robust inoculum
how do we integrate the scale up assist
into our process um so as ma has already
mentioned
we've touched based on some of the great
scale up strategies
used in the industry today and the logic
behind them
so what strategies does scale up assist
support and
how do we choose or what do we choose
excuse me
for our study scale of assess will allow
you to use a constant tip speed
it also supports maintaining a
proportional max gas flow
and lastly it allows you to maintain a
constant pv
and for this study we chose to use
constant pv as our scale up strategy
so here is our scale up assist screen
and i'm just going to kind of take you
through how we inputted
information to get to where we had our
parameters so first we selected our
scale up strategy which is located at
the top
so as you can see that the pv is
selected
we then selected our first vessel in
this case we chose the bioblue 3c
we then chose a tendency and a 50 liter
sub for our other two vessels as you can
see in the screen
um once we selected our vessels all
fields for the scale of parameters will
be auto filled with values
um and this is just something that pops
up and once you start changing
values it'll recalculate
and because the vessels are already
selected into or that we selected are
already
integrated into the software scale up
assist has already done all the work for
us
um as you can see you have the impeller
diameter and the power number
already in there and it's not selectable
because that is already something that
won't change
so next we select our pv box and input a
value of 20
that's what we chose for this study
we then chose our working volume for all
vessels for the 3c we chose to run
a working volume of 3 liters for the 10c
we chose 10 liters and for the 50 liter
sub we chose a working volume of 40
liters
lastly we selected a maximum gas flow
rate of one slpm for a bio blue 3c and
it auto populated the rest of the
parameters needed
for a scale up process for all three
vessels like agitation and max
gas flows
so as i just mentioned we chose our 3c
10c
and the thermoscientific high performa
50 liter bioprocess container
i've already mentioned the working
volumes our agitation like i had
mentioned
was generated from the scallop assist
software so for our 3c
it generated 151 rpm for 10c
it was 126 rpm and for our 50 liter sub
it was 169 rpm our time
our target inoculation for all
experiments was half a million cells per
ml
our temperature was set to 37 degrees c
and kept constant for the duration of
all of our experiments
we used ism do sensors at a set point of
fifty percent
we use the gel filled ph sensor set to
seven
um with a dead band of 0.1 and this is
controlled by cascade to co2
which was our acid and cascade to 0.45
molar
sodium bicarbonate which was our base we
use
three gas auto mixing and set our
gassing range accordingly based on our
scale-up
assist parameters we also always
like to set a minimum flow um which is
usually the the lowest our tmsd will go
in this case it was .04 slpm um and this
is just to avoid any backflow through
our sparge filter since demand is so low
at the beginning of a run
i wanted to highlight our vessel
preparations for a 50 liter sub
because it's a little bit different than
our regular bioblue single-use vessels
so first we unpacked and inspected our
bioprocess container
we connected an aseptic pressure sensor
to our bioprocess container which is
needed to
use the auto and flea and also to detect
any pressure
within our bioprocess container while
running it
we then carefully place it into the
support container which is pictured
to the right we use the auto inflate
feature which is
automatically introducing a specified
amount of air into the bioprocess
container until it's fully inflated like
rich had mentioned
and it also has a built-in safety
feature as he also mentioned
um that will shut down all gases in the
event of high pressure being detected
so that's really great after the
bioprocess container
has been properly inflated we insert our
sensors aseptically by using a sub
probe assembly that has been previously
sterilized by autoclave
and we wanted to do that before we put
any media in because as you can see
on the right hand side um the sensors
are at the bottom
so if we were to do that with the liquid
it'll just be a lot harder so we always
do it before we put any kind of media in
there
um then we in fleet i mean sorry we then
we filled our bioprocess container by
weight
using the load cell um however the
biopress or the bioflow 720 has a
bullish speed addition feature that can
make adding
media simple and as rich
had also mentioned there's also an auto
calibration for
do sensors which saves time and
calibration
makes calibration reproducible between
users which is really important
for our 50 liter sub run we needed a
larger volume of inoculation
um than our previous bioblue cultures
so we first started our culture using an
s41i
we then uh inoculated a bioblue tendency
with a working volume of 10 liters once
we had enough cells
then we grew our culture for a few days
in our bioblue
until it reached approximately 2 million
cells per ml
and then we welded onto our harvest line
on that vessel and inoculated our 50
liter sub
so in this diagram we show our scale of
work that we have successfully completed
using the blue arrows
um our scalab flash culture strategy
that we use for a 50 liter sub run can
also be applied to larger vessel sizes
for example if we wanted to inoculate a
250 liter vessel
we would first prepare our flask culture
like i had mentioned before in our s41i
we then scale up to two of our bioblue
tendencies to allow
and allow the culture for you know to
grow up for a few days
to achieve the calculated density needed
to to inoculate our 250 liter sub
and the same logic could also be applied
to a 500 liter sub
running um the 50 liter sub as a speed
train
to achieve enough culture to inoculate
the 500 liter sub
throughout our experiments we monitor
our metabolic profiles twice daily to
observe how our culture is growing and
to quickly detect if anything is wrong
in our culture
so here we have our metabolic profile of
our 50 liter sub run
our actively growing culture depleted
the initial
supplied glucose by day five lactate
remain
under two and a half grams per liter for
the duration of the run
and ammonia concentrations rose every
day to a toxic level of
10.2 millimoles per liter by day six
we reached a peak antibody production by
day six
of 164 megs per liter
and here we have our cell uh growth
curves and antibiotic productions for
all three vessel sizes
and as you can see they're very similar
it demonstrated that the new scale-up
assist feature can just
decrease uh the process development time
while maintaining
cell yields across various size sizes
and by reactor platform
so in summary choosing an appropriate
strategy is critical for a successful
scale up
of cell culture the bioflow 720 scale of
assist software can
um the features simplify calculations
necessary for scaling
uh relevant parameters and
finally we've demonstrated the process
uh
possibility excuse me of matching yields
for three liter to
50 liter sub bioreactor culture and to
find out more
um you can scan our qr code for our
application note regarding our cell
culture scale up workflow
and at this time i'll give it back to
allen
and we will take some questions
thank you amanda richard ma for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
um that we will address
is that the c train sorry
why did you show multiple bible 10c runs
and not more runs in the bible 3c or 50c
50 liter amanda please
okay so we did more runs using the
bioblue
tendency because we knew we were going
to need a higher inoculation density for
a 50 liter subculture
so we wanted to figure out how fast our
cells
were growing in order to figure out the
best time to harvest ourselves
and as we mentioned that we found that
the
the correct density for us for this run
was around 2 million cells per mil
and that's basically why we have extra
runs for our 10c
okay thank you
another question that we have um
do we have or are the power numbers of
stainless steel
glass vessels released for 1 liter and
10 liter
not sure who can answer that best i i
could answer that always this is rich
miro
um within the scale-up assist
autoclavable
vessels for bioflow 320
one liter three liter five liter and 10
liter the water jacketed version
are included
okay how quickly
does the software trigger or respond to
a drift
from ideal settings of temperature do or
ph
i could also answer that all one those
loops are controlled using a pid
response um those some can also be set
up with a deadband
so to answer the question the as soon as
the present value drift from the set
point
the instrument will begin to control to
try to correct the error
but that could also be tempered by
introducing a dead band if you don't
want
um you know instantaneous control or
correction of
by adding a base for example
all right thank you rich
it a question on the scale-up assist
software
is it only offered on the bioflow 720
controller
or is it standalone software that we
could use to scale the 50 liter sellers
in blue
to the high performance or other places
is it just scaling
or just calculating p over v and vvm for
you
so if i understand the question
correctly
i'll try to answer the the software is
integrated into
the bioflow 720 so it is
only available currently as a feature of
that product
we are looking at the possibility of
integrating it into
our scada platforms but that would be
for future release not today
and then to answer the second half of
the question
if it's calculating the recommended p to
v
or the tip speed based on the initial
parameter set for for sort of what i
call the driving vessel the first and
the first column and that could be done
for either scale up or scaled down
so some applications i may call
that you you want to know from a 500
liter what it may be at 50 liter and
then down to a 1 liter or whatever your
scale down
so that could be done in in either
direction
okay thank you rich can the pilot system
handle cell culture
with microbeads
[Music]
um so i guess i'll answer that also it
doesn't mind
so there are application notes available
from
thermo fisher scientific supporting the
use
of micro carrier beads with in the
thermal high performa 5 to 1
sub so the product is capable of if the
instrument the bioflow 720 could of
course support that application
maybe an extended question there has the
process been used
in the production of cell exosomes
so i don't have record of any
documentation
uh ma perhaps would you be able to
answer that
i can do a passion partial answer um
[Music]
the exosome especially from
stem cells is fairly new and uh
from our bench scale we just actually
started
doing some applications for it
so we have one application note just
came out that was using a bench scale
for
a chemical stem cell exosome production
we've not looked into something at the
pilot scale we have another application
coming up that is going to be the same
application but using the dos box
so at this point the information that we
have is limited to bench and small scale
but in the future if the exosome market
becomes
substantial we will probably look into
it
but right now we don't have anything in
the pilot scale
thank you mom the c train
showed i think this would be for amanda
this question
would it also work to inoculate a 2000
liter culture
yes i can answer that um yeah using the
seed train
strategy that we've come up with
certainly you can
adapt it to your process accordingly
um to figure out how much inoculation
density you need um
to get to the 200 or 2000 liter rather
um
but basically kind of like how i said
for a 500
liter maybe you would use the 50 liter
as a part of the scale up
um to grow up enough cells and
inoculation density into
your 500 liter so you would have to take
it as that type of example and i would
i would think that um you just scale it
up to what you need
thank you so some questions on the
bioflow 720 controller is it
gmp able with fat sat ioq
is a system 21 cfr compliance and
can data be escalated to a scada
or delta v controller
yeah hi all in this is rich so
yeah the the instrument can be supplied
with
a full documentation package including
fat
sat iq oq
and then instrument documentation which
could be then be used
to support implementation into a
regulated process
the the controller supports 21cfr
part 11. it allows the
local controller to be locked out and
and kind of driven by a external scada
which would
be recording and monitoring interaction
with the device as well as
creating a batch report so that data
could be used
in submission
so was there another part i'm sorry i
don't have the question in front of me
the use of scada software
or delta v yes it's compatible with the
eppendorf scada platforms
and delta v will be one of our future
releases
okay thank you does the scale-up assist
function
equally for scaling down to smaller
sized vessels
i think this was and to answer partially
in a previous question but yes
um that there is no restriction to go in
either direction
you could you could scale up or scale
down
just equivalently thank you
um a quick question from
uh how do you control or
check for any kind of microbial
contamination through the process
maybe amanda that's something you can
answer how do you do it in the lab
sure uh so there's a couple indicators
of
a possible contamination um
your maybe you're gassing especially in
the initial
type of uh like inoculation your gassing
might
be very high and that's unusual uh
typically in the beginning
so that would kind of put up a red flag
co can drop to zero
um if you actually physically take a
sample from your bioreactor
and look under a microscope usually you
can tell right away
um also there's usually a little bit
discoloration
in your culture um you know uh it's more
like orangey typically depending on what
type of
media you're using of course but it's
more that color
and certainly depending how long it it's
been it can
have a smell as well so but i think the
best way to check would be actually
taking a sample and looking under the
microscope for seeing any
abnormalities all right
another question i think for you amanda
what was the volume of the 50 liter sub
when it was inoculated
um i believe we put in about since we
ran it at 40 liter max
volume um i believe we put 30 liters in
there to begin with
um and then adjusted accordingly
uh the media needed after we inoculated
so um we inoculated for inoculation
density of
about half a million cells per ml like i
had mentioned
so i can't i can't remember off the top
of my head but i want to say it was we
inoculated about 10 liters of our our
bioreactor culture and then
um it was a 40 liter total
so 30 to start
okay thank you another question on the
scale-up assist software
if it's freely available and if the
software
is well available for non-single-use
bioreactors
for example dusky bioblock system
so freely available it's included
with the instrument it's a part of the
integrated software package so it's a
tool integrated in
we are evaluating if that could be
added to eppendorf's data platforms
or derived in some other way
so that it could be used for customers
who are not operating a bioflow 720
and then as i mentioned earlier the
the bioblue vessel portfolio from 0.25
up through the thermo 2000 liter are
included as well as the bioflow 320 one
liter through 10 liter
and additional vessels will continue to
be added
but there are no other vessels to answer
the question
included in that software to date
okay thank you two questions on
compatibility of the controller to
different vessels so one is about the
compatibility to the bioblue 50c vessel
and the other is it able to manage
single-use fermentation
such as a 30 or 300 liter from thermal
feature
uh so the 720 is currently only
capable of cell culture applications
but fermentation and specifically
the thermo fisher single-use
fermentation system
is something we are evaluating for
future release future options
but we do not have it available at
launch
okay thank you rich there's a question
on can we show the last barcode again i
meant i don't know if you still have the
control
if you can show the barcode for the last
uh
application note there we go thank you
um another question is
uh the use of the you use the p overv
of 20 is it possible to enter higher
values
um i can answer this one
so yes the answer is yes so if you
increase in the scale-up graph at the
end of my
portion um i have two graphs one goes to
uh 0.7 tip speed and the other one to
1.0 so if the customer is able to their
cell line is able to sustain a higher
agitation speed
then they can expand the pv values
and also it depends on the vessel so 10
liter and
50 liter can go more than 50 pv
where the 3 liter is a little bit less i
think it's like 35 or 40 pv
so yes yes the 20 is not the upper limit
thank you um a question
has come in in the sub what was the dom
ph
strategy amanda i think that would be
good for you
okay so the dio
strategy 50 is usually what we use for
all of our cho cultures um we had
done some work with uh getting the pi
values
tuned to our process um which we have a
scale-up
or we have an application for that that
um
we can send to you about how to do that
um the ph
again was uh basically a normal strategy
that we've used
uh ph of seven that's what our cells
like and we didn't
want our dead band to be too high we
were trying to limit
any variations of ph so we kept it at
0.1 dead band
all right and what was the highest cell
density
and how did you reduce the ammonia
levels
from increasing as the cells grow
i guess that one's me let me uh
let me actually go back a graph here i
think everybody's probably done with
that
um so because they were a batch run we
didn't do anything to
you know curve the ammonia um
the batch run you don't add anything so
it is what it
is type thing um
the highest density i believe was about
15
million cells per ml if i remember right
and that was uh with one of our bioblue
uh 3c or 10cs rather we got a high
density there
all right you scaled by p over v
how was the p over v value selected or
developed
i think maybe i want to take that yeah i
can take this
so amanda if you have control can you
just go back to the end of my session
there's
a slide that shows how we actually
measured
the power number and we'll go back there
and
um
this one uh i don't
see dollars it's not a delay so
um this one is the previous one
yeah go back a little further to the
power number
power number okay
there you go okay data so
to measure to to come up with pv
um there's a pv equation i can you you
can see to the right
on the bottom it says power input moving
equals
you know power numbers and kind of a
bunch of numbers
so this is the equation you would
calculate the power
input for volume from a power number
and for each vessel we would have to
mechanically determine the power number
as i mentioned briefly during the
presentation
using the devices in the picture you
have a
torque sensor flexor a flexible adapter
and then there's a particle that we have
released to how to measure the power
number
and these devices are custom made
so that's one difficult part is not
everybody has
the ability to measure the power number
by torque
that's why we measured them for most of
our products
used in the scalability system and we
provide them
thank you mark i think it's
uh we have time for one more question
are you able to input your own vessel
criteria into scale-up assist
i'll uh i'll answer that but perhaps
also amanda if you could
progress to the screen that shows the
scale up assist
sure and one second okay
but to answer the question yes so where
you currently see
from me is that okay or do you want
yours that's fine
okay um you can see the selection of the
various bioblue and sub
products those are actually drop downs
and one of the available selections in
the drop down
is user defined and the user defined
this includes blank fields that you
would need to know certain
certain criteria like a power number the
impeller diameter
and and that would then allow you to
input
your own user defined and use that in
the scale of model if that's not one of
the vessels we show in the list
okay thank you so thank you ma rich and
amanda
any final comments from you for the
audience
um just to thank you for attending
today's webinar we enjoyed presenting it
or
you know i know speaking for my
colleagues we always enjoy
the opportunity to present products and
in the work we do here at eppendorf
yes thank you guys for participating
and thanks alvin for uh managing the
session
appreciate it no problem so thank you
again for your time today
and your important research amanda that
you did in the lab
we would also like to thank lap roots
and all involved people at eppondorf for
underwriting
on the writing today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience to for joining us today and
their interesting
questions questions that we did not have
time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by
one of the speakers or one of the other
eppendorf team members
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webinar is part of the online
events streamlining by a
biologic scale up we welcome you to stay
on the platform
in the auditorium you will find a panel
discussion on the challenges in biologic
scale up
also there is an information booth an
applications lab
where you can find more information
about scale up applications
and our new product to buyer for 720.
see you there
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
rules will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live events
until the next time
and goodbye for me as well